we have something in common i'm told we
both come from big families is that
right yeah yeah I'm gonna be oh you're
one of eight much I'm one of six yeah
kind of more or less yeah you're always
meeting a sibling you didn't know you
had in the bath the word work do they oh
yeah okay so where do you fall in the
lineup I'm the middle kid in the middle
yeah I'm before I was middle - yes in
the middle you feel like hey someone pay
attention to me and then it becomes this
sickness right here was like for you to
do that and you know I had to guard my
plate you know because it was so many of
us when they're dealing with this stuff
they want to try to eat - I was a slow
eater but now you know I think I eat too
fast because I'm so used to them trying
to go after my stuff so I eat everything
I do the same thing I seriously I eat
because they would put the food out and
we'd all be like ah and so when I eat
now it'll be just my wife and I in a
restaurant I put my arm near my food and
people said that's what pris that's what
they do in Pearson you don't keep people
okay now did you all play together
growing up imagine yeah man we did all
the time we actually used to play this
one game we used to go to the for serve
out in Chicago it's like a picnic area
for families and we used to go there it
needs to be a big Hill a grass Hill and
then on the side of the grass here it
was like a wooden like you could walk
now it wasn't stairs it was just flat
and we will grab garbage cans hops and
slide down it and it's light underside
woods like like like a sweat like sweat
riding but uh I don't know what we call
it but it's just a game but we'll slide
down the wooden part not the grass but
the wooden part and my grandmother and
my I always used to say don't slide down
that because you guys might hurt
yourself we didn't listen we did it
anyway and my brother ended up the
garbage can top ended up sliding from
under his foot and he ended up getting a
splinter maybe this big and this thing
up his butt but not his heart not his
butthole but like
what is it tonight
I brought you out here to kind of clean
things up flow and now suddenly there's
a there's a baseball bat you know sorry
I distinctly remember you asking her
I've hurt any of her siblings ever got
splinters in there but you know you said
garbage kids I thought you were getting
in garbage sitting on top of the fence
and I was thinking like hey that
actually sounds like fun to get into
garbage and roll down oh that's nasty
okay I guess I'm the crazy
so is he okay I mean I mean well my he
laid down a blanket in the grass where
we were picnicking yeah and um on Sam
what what do you don't play with the
rest of the kids and she swatted ants
but he said ah and she said what's wrong
and somebody ended up pulling his pants
down like what's wrong with you and they
saw the splinter they ended up getting
it out but they poured beer on it
because we don't have alcohol or like
they had beer and started sizzling up so
I guess he didn't get infected so he
could
[Applause]
you